the cast of westworld rachel smith joins
us from madame tussauds new york in
times square i know she got the scoop
oh yeah kev i'm getting to the bottom of
it oh i hit the premiere for season four
with a gang including tessa thompson and
luke hemsworth who might just have a
brotherly battle on his hands
tess has had the opportunity now to work
with both you and your brother chris oh
yeah
so who would tessa say is the funnier
brother come on
definitely no chris he's not lying like
we've spent time with all of them and
and luke hemsworth is the funniest one
yes but i don't compare they're all
beautiful hemsworthians like you need
them you need them all
when are we going to complete the
trilogy and have you work with liam
maybe when i complete the trifecta i'll
just like vanish into air like i don't
know well who knows i'm kind of scared i
want to liam i think he's a brilliant
actor i just don't know what will happen
to me
you're kind made a sport out of hunting
us
as for tessa and luke's westworld
co-star aaron paul he's got two little
ones at home and recently showed off his
special skill i have a four four and a
half year old daughter and she was born
with a lot of hair and so i kind of
started learning how to braid pretty
early on i love correcting people when
they say oh my god your mom did such a
great job
on your hair and my daughter goes no my
daddy did it just makes me so proud
how was it the second time around he's
three months old and he's just
the sweetest most gentle kid i love him
to death this is a story about a girl
evan rachel wood is also back for season
four this sunday on hbo as a newish
character with potentially the same love
interest james marsden is back is he
teddy who is he is he good is he bad
then tell me more i know it's like ross
and rachel you just are like waiting so
desperately for them to make it in their
happy ending
[Music]